72 heures après l'incendie qui a ravagé
cet immeuble de la rue d'Odin à Blois
terre de Loire Habitat le propriétaire
des lieux était ce mardi à pied d'oeuvre
pour trouver des solutions pérennes de
relogement pour les 19 familles
sinistrées qui vivaient sur place dans
l'urgence tout le monde a été accueilli
chez des proches ou à l'hôtel mais il
est temps maintenant de penser à la près
aujourd'hui chaque locataire devait donc
recevoir un bon de visite pour un
nouveau logement sur les 19 familles
en gros on a trouvé des solutions pour
17 et on a deux où on fera appel à nos
confrères Loir-et-Cher logement et 3F
l'autre préoccupation des locataires
s'est également de pouvoir retourner
chercher leurs affaires car tous sont
partis dans la précipitation impossible
pour l'instant samedi soir la ville de
Blois apprise un arrêté de péril compte
tenu de l'état de dangerosité du
bâtiment en lien là aussi avec le avec
le bailleur et le 10 et la police
nationale puisqu'il y a une enquête en
cours on va apprendre un nouvel arrêté
qui permettra de créer une sorte de
cordon sanitaire qui permettra donc aux
habitants de rentrer dans leurs
appartements récupérer leurs affaires
une enquête a été ouverte pour
comprendre comment le feu a pris ce
samedi après-midi dans le dernier étage
de cet immeuble de nombreux riverains
ont assisté à l'évacuation des résidents
et à l'intervention des pompiers
certains ont même donné un coup de main
de l'autre côté de l'immeuble dans la
façade il y avait une personne qui était
bloquée les flammes étaient dans son
appartement puis avec les riverains on
avait pris tous une échelle on était 8
et on l'a une personne qui a réussi à
descendre de l'autre côté qui était
l'autre côté et puis après les pompiers
sont venus ils ont sauvé les personnes
mais c'est ça allait vraiment vraiment
très très vite moi j'ai jamais vu ça
donc là ça m'a fait peur quoi donc vous
habitez dans le même type d'immeuble
voilà tout à fait ce matin le bailleur
social se disait pessimiste quant à
l'avenir de la résidence la toiture a
été totalement dévastée l'eau utilisée
par les pompiers a également fait des
dégâts le bâtiment construit dans les
années 60 ne sera peut-être plus jamais
habitable